THE HEAD COACH OF THE OREGON
DUCKS DANA ALTMAN AS PROMISED
COACH. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
KNOW YOU'RE A BUSY MAN. GOT A
LOT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US HERE ON
THE RICH EISEN SHOW. THIS IS
DAN HALEY.
GLAD TO BE A PART OF IT DAN.
WELL, CONGRATULATIONS ONCE
AGAIN TO MAKING IT TO THE
SWEET 16. THIS IS NOTHING NEW
FOR YOU. YOU HAVE BEEN HERE
BEFORE YOU'VE BEEN TO THE
ELITE EIGHT. YOU'VE BEEN TO
WELL, WE'VE GOT UNIQUE PIECES
THIS YEAR DAN. WE WE'RE
STARTING, YOU KNOW, FIVE GUYS
THAT ARE ALL SIX FIVE SIX
SIX AND YOU KNOW, WE CAN
REALLY SPREAD TEAMS OUT. WE
HAVE HAD SOME DIFFICULTIES
GARDEN INSIDE WHICH WILL
CREATE BIG PROBLEMS WITH USC
WITH THEIR SIZE AND CREATED
PROBLEMS LAST NIGHT WITH IOWA.
BUT THIS TEAM, YOU KNOW CAN
GET IT GOING OFFENSIVELY WHEN
THEY DO THEY'RE TOUGH TO
GUARD. WE'VE GOT ALL FIVE
GUYS.
START CAN SHOOT THE THREE ALL
FIVE FROM PUT IT ON THE FLOOR
AND MAKE PLAYS. SO WE'RE A
UNIQUE TEAM OFFENSIVELY AND
DEFENSIVELY WE TRY TO CHANGE
THINGS UP A LOT SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF OF THEIR
HE'S AGAINST US BUT BEEN A
FUN GROUP TO WORK WITH WE'VE
GONE THROUGH INJURIES. WE'VE
GONE THROUGH THE COVID. WE
LOST OUR POSTMAN WHO IS A
GREAT PLAYER DONE IN POLY
DANTE THE SIX CAME TO YOUR
ACL INJURY, WHICH MADE US GO
SMALL AND THE GUYS HAVE
WELL, THE NUMBER THAT REALLY
STOOD OUT TO ME WAS NOT THE
NUMBER EVERYBODY WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHEN YOU GUYS BEAT IOWA
AND PUT 95 POINTS UP ON THE
BOARD AND 56 IN THE FIRST
HALF WAS A 25 ASSISTS THE
BALL MOVEMENT. YOU MUST HAVE
BEEN ELATED AND I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE DONE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON BUT
YOU'VE NEVER PUT 95 POINTS UP
ON THE BOARD, AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT YOU'VE HAD 25
ASSISTS IN A GAME. MAYBE YOU
DAN YOU'RE RIGHT. I I WAS
REALLY PROUD OF THE GUYS THE
BALL MOVEMENT LAST NIGHT WAS
THE BEST WE'VE HAD WE'RE
BEATING OFF PENETRATION THE
HELP WOULD COME WE KICK IT
OUT. WE HIT 11 THREES BECAUSE
WE TOOK GOOD THREES AND THE
BALL MOVEMENT WAS REALLY GOOD
AND AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S CRITICAL TO OUR
SUCCESS. I KEEP EMPHASIZING
IT TO THE GUYS THAT YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
BALL GAMES. IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE BALL MOVEMENT THE SHOTS.
AND YOU KNOW, WE WE ARE GOOD
DEFENSIVE TEAM. NOT A GREAT
DEFENSIVE TEAM, BUT A GOOD
DEFENSIVE TEAM AND WE JUST
GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MOVE
THE BALL AND WE'VE GOT FIVE
GUYS WHO ARE AVERAGING IN
DOUBLE FIGURES. SO WE'VE GOT
TO PICK OUT THE WEEK DEFENDER
AND AND TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT. WHAT ARE THE NUMBERS
YOU TALK ABOUT THE THE BALL
MOVEMENT THE 25 ASSISTS YOU
MENTIONED THE 11 THREES. YOU
ALSO HAD TEN DUNKS IN THE
GAME. WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
BE PUTTING UP THERE ON THE
WHITEBOARD AND YOUR PREGAME
OOH THE GUYS IF WE DO THIS
THIS AND THIS AGAINST USC THAT
THEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THIS GAME. WELL, THE FIRST
THING IS WE GOT TO REBOUND
THE BALL WITH THEIR SIZE, YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE VERY GOOD
REBOUNDING TEAM. AND SO WE
CAN'T BE GIVEN UP SECOND
THIRD SHOTS. THEY PLAYED VERY
WELL AGAINST KANSAS LAST
NIGHT IF YOU CAUGHT THAT GAME
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T GIVE
THEM ANY SECOND SHOTS WHEN WE
LOST HIM IN LA
LA THEY GOT OFF TO A GREAT.
START HITTING THREES. SO
DEFENDING THE THREE DOWN WILL
BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO US,
YOU KNOW, SO THEY'VE GOT A
GREAT BALANCE INSIDE OUT.
OBVIOUSLY THE MOBLEY
BROTHER'S INSIDE GIVE HIM A
ONE-TWO PUNCH INSIDE THE
GUARDS CAN ALL SHOOT THE
THREE SO VERY TOUGH DEFENSIVE
ASSIGNMENT, BUT WE JUST CAN'T
LET HIM GO CRAZY FROM THREE
LIKE THEY DID THE FIRST OF ALL
SO WE HAD YOU ORIGINALLY
SCHEDULED FOR A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER IN THE SHOW, BUT YOU
WERE ON THE PHONE WITH A
RELATIVELY IMPORTANT PERSON
ABSOLUTELY. NO, CHRIS PORTIER
ARE OFF GUARD IS UP FOR THE
VERY PRESTIGIOUS JERRY WEST
AWARD. HE'S ONE OF THE FIVE
FINALISTS AND YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY I'M VERY BIASED
BUT HE'S MY GUY AND YOU KNOW,
I'M SURE GLAD FOR HIM AND
HE'S HONORED THAT HE'S BEING
CONSIDERED FOR THE AWARD
BECAUSE ALL FIVE OF THE GUYS
ARE VERY DESERVING. BUT AGAIN,
HE'S MY GUY AND I'M HOPING
RICHARD WHO WAS OUR POINT
GUARD LAST YEAR WON THE BOB
COUSY AWARD AND YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A VERY PRESTIGIOUS
AWARD FOR OFF GUARDS, AND
WE'RE SURE HOPING THAT CHRIS
WINS THEN HELI FILLING IN FOR
RICH EISEN ON THE RICH EYES
AND SHOW TALKING TO DANA
ALTMAN HEAD COACH AT OREGON
YOU MENTIONED CHRIS DUARTE 23
POINTS LAST NIGHT. LISTEN,
YOU'VE BEEN IN OREGON FOR 11
SEASONS HAD TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS FIVE SWEET 16S.
YOU'VE BEEN TO A COUPLE LEAD
A TO FINAL FOUR. WHERE DOES
CHRIS RANKED?
AMONG THE PLAYERS THAT YOU'VE
COACHED IN, OREGON.
WELL, HE'S RIGHT AT THE TOP.
I MEAN, WE'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE YOU GO ALL THE WAY
BACK TO VOTE. JOSEPH WAS
A PAC-10 PLAYER. THAT WAS ALL.
ALL-CONFERENCE DILLON BROOKS
JORDAN BELL, CHRIS BOUCHER,
YOU KNOW RICHARD WE'VE HAD
SOME REALLY GOOD ONES AND YOU
KNOW CHRISTMAS RUNNER-UP
PLAYER OF THE YEAR AND THE
COACHES BOAT TO MOBLEY, BUT
HE WAS THE AP PLAYER OF THE
MOBLEY. BUT HE WAS THE AP
PLAYER OF THE YEAR IN THE
PAC-12. HE'S PLAYED THROUGH
INJURY HIS EFFICIENCY NUMBERS
DAN OR ARE OFF THE CHART.
HE'S 53 PERCENT FROM THE
FIELD 42 FROM
UM THREE AND AN 80 PERCENT
FROM THE LINE REBOUNDS FIVE
REBOUNDS A GAME YEARS ON THE
ALT DEFENSIVE TEAM, YOU KNOW,
SO HE'S ALL AROUND VERY GOOD
PLAYER. HE WAS A JUNIOR
COLLEGE ALL-AMERICAN AND
THERE'S TWO YEARS WITH US
WILL BE THE PAC-12 CHAMPS
BOTH YEARS, YOU KNOW, AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE
PLAYING WE'VE GOT A TOUGH ONE
AGAINST USC ON SUNDAY AND AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MOVE ON TO
THE ELITE EIGHT. YOU GOT TO
KEEP EVERYBODY FOCUSED.
GOTTA KEEP THESE GUYS LOOSE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING FOR THE
NEXT FEW DAYS WHEN YOU GUYS
AREN'T ON THE PRACTICE COURT.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A DIFFERENT
SITUATION THIS YEAR IN THE
TOURNAMENT. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO KEEP THESE GUYS
ENTERTAINED AND HOW DO YOU
KEEP FROM OVER-SCHEDULING?
THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS WONDER
IS A HEAD COACH. YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO TOO MUCH, BUT YOU
WANT TO KEEP THEM ACTIVE AND
BUSY RIGHT DAN. THIS IS
SITUATION HERE. YOU KNOW,
WE'VE GOT FIVE DAYS BEFORE WE
PLAY NOW AND WE ARE
SET HERE ON THE 14TH FLOOR
OF THE MARRIOTT AND AND WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO GO.
ANYWHERE, SO IT IS VERY
DIFFERENT FOR A GUYS AND
DIFFERENT FOR OUR COACHING
STAFF. WE'VE NEVER HAD
ANYTHING. USUALLY YOU HAVE A
A TEAM HOTEL AND YOU GOT ALL
THE PARENTS IN AND YOU KNOW
THE BAND THE CHEERLEADERS
EVERYBODY'S AROUND YOU GOT
FANS AND IT'S KIND OF A
FESTIVE ATMOSPHERE, BUT NOW
JUST REAL QUIET AND EVERYBODY
HAS THEIR OWN FLOOR. THEY'VE
GOT ALL 16 TEAMS HERE IN THE
MARRIOTT AND YOU KNOW,
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG FOR
FIVE DAYS FOR EVERYBODY. BUT
I YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO
THE ZOO TODAY THE END UP TO
TRY TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT
AND YOU KNOW, JUST TRY TO GET
OUTSIDE A LITTLE BIT AND WE
DIDN'T DO MUCH FOR PRACTICE.
WE PLAYED YESTERDAY AND WE
DON'T PLAY AGAIN TILL SUNDAY.
SO HE EVEN AFTER TODAY WE'LL
HAVE FOUR DAYS TO PREPARE FOR
USC. AND S